yes one of the Avengers flag characters
is Captain America and America is like
the last country to get this movie makes
little sense very little sense the
Avengers if my voice sounds a little
weird cuz I'm coming down with something
that's sequentially taking my voice away
so we'll try to power through this
review before I lose my voice entirely
which I'm sure will happen by the end of
this video
all right so four years ago in the movie
Iron Man we were promised the Avengers
and even then we were like is that real
and now it has come to fruition now if
this sucks it's all for nothing that's
kind of a shitty prospect but it's just
the reality of the situation all right
if you remember when I heard Joss Whedon
was the director of the Avengers movie I
was like that's perfect because Joss
Whedon does a good job at taking a bunch
of different characters and making them
all relevant and to that I still hold
and in the Avengers he shows I loved it
I was watching The Avengers I'm like
everyone is relevant black widows more
relevant that she was an Iron Man to let
us take a moment for Scarlett Johansson
I'm in a sentence worth it when you're
watching the scene with Thor it's all
about Thor scene with Captain America
it's all about Captain America and yes
Mark Ruffalo was good as Bruce Banner he
only hooks out like twice in the movie I
was like I'd like to see more Hulk
however when he does Hulk out it's the
coolest ever
once again the Incredible Hulk is this
unstoppable force and it's he's a badass
and not only did all these Avengers
characters work but they were all
believable because they didn't like each
other at first they could have just as
easily been like oh no we're all coming
together let's fight for truth and
justice they didn't go that route they
were like now all these strong
personalities they're gonna clash no for
me what really locks it down and makes
it like oh yeah all these movies have
now converged in the Avengers is the
supporting cast some of the supporting
cast from some of the other Marvel
movies that are Avengers build up pretty
much there in the Avengers too so that
was really cool that like locked it down
they could have just had the main heroes
and that's it but now they have a couple
supporting characters that's awesome and
what would the Avengers be without a
sweet-ass villain moment of silence Loki
is the man he is seduced badass right
when he first comes on the scene you're
like I don't know how they're gonna beat
this guy he is more of a badass in the
Avengers than he wasn't Thor and I liked
him in Thor yeah the dude was pretty
unstoppable pretty awesome I guess my
only crap about the movie is there was
no Red Skull in it I mean spoiler alert
I don't think that spoiler saying
something's not in the movie but it's
not in the movie and maybe they're
saving em for the sequel
Avengers is 2 hours and 20 minutes long
that's completely perfect in fact when
you're watching the movie you're like I
don't want it to end usually with a two
hour 20 minute movie by the time it ends
you're ready for it to end now the
Avengers you're like no I want to see
him Hulk out more I want to see Iron Man
fly one day I wanna see Thor do the
thing you know with like the with the
hammer and the lightning and the cool I
mean the last twenty minutes of the
Avengers alone or worth it the last 20
minutes of this movie I'm telling you
man just all sorts of kick-ass but other
than that you have another two hours of
movie that's just also really good it is
kind of an end of an era you know I mean
yeah they'll have another Avengers movie
and they'll all come together again but
it won't be as cool as that first time
you see all these characters together in
one movie the original Avengers man I'm
telling you this is a feeling that you
don't really get movies nowadays
everything built up to this and it built
up perfectly and the movie was just
badass and awesome it's not every day a
four-year plan pays off for us the
viewers so I will say the Avengers is
awesome tacular
if you're a Marvel fan you'll love it if
you love superhero movies in general
you'll love it this is what cool summer
movies should feel like it's like the
first time I saw Star Trek I don't think
there's a lot of people who can come out
of this movie motor scooters drugs so
I'd be seeing the Avengers yet what did
you think comment below let me know odds
are if you're not in America you have
seen it by now because like I said we're
the last ones to get it and as always if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more